good evening I'm Sharon Kelly Roth and
it's my pleasure to welcome you to books
and company and to welcome our c-span
viewers tonight our featured guest is
noted historian Kevin Boyle author of
arc of justice a saga of race civil
rights and murder in the Jazz Age this
book has been nominated for the
prestigious National Book Award for
nonfiction and rightly so for seldom is
history presented in such a powerful
suspenseful way yes it's the story of
one brave and determined black man dr.
ocean sweet but it's more than that it's
a look at America in 1925 when jazz was
king the automobile factories were
thriving in Detroit and blacks were
moving north to find work but along with
them came the Klan to incite hatred and
a new organization called the National
Association for the Advancement of
Colored People known today as the
n-double-a-cp led by w eb des bois rally
blacks to raise their voices and to
begin the march toward equality dignity
and self-respect
perhaps because famed attorney Clarence
Darrow represented dr. sweet in a court
drama the case got national attention
and as a result the world saw the dawn
of America's racial Awakening
I am honored to introduce you to the man
responsible for this gripping book
please give a warm books and company
welcome to the author of arc of justice
associate professor of history at Ohio
State University
Kevin Boyle
[Applause]
thank you all for coming and
particularly thanks to the folks at
books and company for having me
arc of justice I was talking to
interviewer the other day an archive
just the interviewer said to me what is
this book which stunned me
I hadn't been asked that question before
and what I said was in a fumbling sort
of way well it's a history book and it
is what it talks about is a particular
time in a particular place at a
particular social dynamic that I think
is really important but what it tries to
do is it tries to talk about those big
issues in a story and the story it tells
starts on September 9th of 1925 late in
the afternoon and what I thought I'd do
is I'd read you just a tiny little bit
of what's happened at that moment by
5:30 the late summer Sun was already
starting to sink toward the row of
tightly packed houses the light that had
been filtering through the drawn
curtains began to fade but the gathering
darkness did nothing to dissipate the
heat that had built up over the course
of the day with the windows barely
cracked open and the door shut fast the
bungalow on the corner was enveloped in
a suffocating stillness dr. ocean suite
sat at the card table he'd set up in the
dining room he was a handsome man short
dark and powerfully built a month short
of 30 he looked 10 years older his
hairline was receding his waistline was
expanding his face was taking on the
roundness of middle-age other men might
have hated to see their youth slipping
from them sweet cultivated the illusion
of maturity where he came from black men
were permanently boys never worthy of
white men's respect never their equals
dr. sweet was no boy he was a
professional man better educated
wealthier more accomplished than most of
the whites he encountered he wanted
others to know at the moment they saw
him so he favored tailored suits well
cut and subdued he bought crisp white
shirts and tasteful ties he wore the
round tortoiseshell glasses popular with
college men he kept his mustache neatly
trimmed
his hair is stylish Lee short sweet
attempted to project the casual
confidence the instinctual authority
that set factors apart from the ordinary
run of men it didn't come to him
naturally as a child he'd shared in the
back-breaking work of his parents
Central Florida farm tending the fields
his father rented hauling water from the
stream so that his mother could do the
laundry caring for the ever-growing
brood of brothers and sisters who filled
every cranny of the tiny farmhouse his
parents had built by hand his mother and
father had taught him what they could
immersing him in the religious
traditions that had sustained the family
through generations of struggle making
him want to succeed then when he was 13
years old they had sent ocean away not
because they wanted one less mouth to
feed though lifting that burden was a
blessing but because they loved him get
away while you're young they told him go
north get an education and he did though
he left Florida with only as much as he
could glean from six years in a one-room
schoolhouse that shut down when harvest
time came it took him 12 more years to
fulfill his parents instructions a dozen
long hard years of schooling to master
the material that would make him an
educated man and earn the pride that was
expected to the races best men all the
while working is a serving boy for white
people washing dirty dishes waiting
tables carting luggage up hotel stairs
just to pay tuition and buy the books as
professors required him to read ocean
never excelled but he got an education
as fine in education as on almost any
man in America colored or white could
claim by age 25 he earned his Bachelor
of Science degree from Wilberforce
University in Ohio and his medical
degree from Washington DC's Howard
University the jewel in the crown of
Negro colleges he come to Detroit in
1921 with virtually nothing but but in
the four years since he'd built a
thriving practice down in Black Bottom
the city's largest ghetto he'd earned
the respect of his colleagues at Dunbar
Memorial the city's best colored
Hospital he helped his brother Otis
launch his professional career best of
all Ocean had found in his wife Gladys a
young woman of grace charm and social
standing a wonderfully suitable doctor's
wife as a gift to them both and a
balm for their pain Oshin had taken his
bride in a sort of adventure one reads
about in novels a year-long stay in
Vienna and Paris where he completed
postgraduate studies on the cutting edge
of medical science yet despite all those
victories ocean remained deep down the
frightened Florida farm boy trying to
carry his family's expectations on his
narrow shoulders he didn't doubt his
ability he knew he was a fine physician
better than most but he often tried too
hard to impress to find just the right
phrase to strike just the right pose to
keep just the right distance to reassure
himself now as the darkness slowly
descended around him his carefully
constructed veneer crumbled away didn't
feel sure of himself
he felt terribly terribly afraid the
fear he felt that moment was in reaction
to the circumstances he found himself
previous days September 8th of 1925
ocean and Gladys had moved into their
new home their first home on the east
side of Detroit it should have been a
moment of great pride if any of your
home owners you know what it means to
move into the very first home he'll ever
know but for them it was absolutely
terrifying because that house on the
corner of Garland and Charlevoix on the
east side of Detroit sat in an all-white
neighborhood an ocean and Gladys were
black they understood that when they
moved into that house their white
neighbors might well gather outside to
drive them out they understood in other
words that by taking possession of that
house they risked the wrath of a white
mob and for ocean suite in particular
nothing was more terrifying because as I
said in that short passage their ocean
suite was a son of the south he grown up
in a small town in Central Florida town
by the name of Bartow at a time when the
southern system of segregation the Jim
Crow system was just being
created when it was at its absolutely
most vicious during sweets childhood
several african-american men had been
lynched in his town one of them a 16
year old had been literally burned at
the stake in his town he knew what a
white mob could do living under the
burdens of Jim Crow was a crushing
weight for African Americans to bear but
what oshins parents had decided what
they were determined to do was to see
that their children didn't crumble under
that weight
they weren't political activists there
were ordinary people they owned a tiny
little lot of land which of course was
one of their great prides on the black
side of town but what they taught their
children was that they could move up the
social ladder as far as their abilities
and their hard work would carry them and
that's why when Ocean was 13 years old
they sent him away he was their oldest
boy and they sent him away because only
by sending him away could he begin that
climb up the social ladder and that's
exactly what he did he came up to
Wilberforce just on the road from here
spent eight years at Wilberforce in
those days Wilberforce had a high school
academy because there were so many
african-americans particularly in the
south who didn't have access to a high
school education and so Wilberforce
provided them that finished high school
there he stayed on to get his Bachelor
of Science from Wilberforce in 1917 and
then as I said in that really quick
little passage I read you he moved on to
the very best of the Negro colleges
Howard University which sits on top of a
hill in Washington DC and absolutely
gorgeous campus sitting on a hill
overlooking the capital where he got his
medical degree graduated 1921 in other
words what he had done is he had
fulfilled all of his parents
expectations
he's fulfilled his own expectations he
was the embodiment of the American dream
and he could have gone home I could have
gone back to Bartow back in those days
Bartow didn't have an african-american
doctor so you can you all imagine what
it would have meant if he had gone back
but ocean suite was an ambitious man he
wanted to succeed in a way that a small
town down in Florida wasn't gonna let
him succeed so instead he decided to
move to the greatest boomtown in America
and he's done these days it might seem a
little odd to say this but that was
Detroit Michigan
he arrived in the autumn of 1921 and he
couldn't have picked a more critical
time to arrive because Detroit was then
in a period of absolutely phenomenal
growth all of it driven by the fact that
in those days too trait was the center
of the greatest growth industry in the
world automobile manufacturing and what
that was doing was attracting waves of
newcomers up to Detroit in search of
work most of those newcomers were
immigrants they were poles they were
Italians they were Slavs they were
Russians they were Greeks they were
Syrians people attracted from around the
world to get those fabulous wages that
Henry Ford would pay along with that
huge stream of immigrants came another
large stream of african-americans coming
out of the south coming for the very
self same reasons good work and the
knowledge that in cities like Detroit
there was no Jim Crow and so Detroit's
black population had skyrocketed in 1910
there were 5700 african-americans living
in Detroit
that's all 5700 that was smaller than
the popular black population of Bartow
or at least the surrounding countryside
of Bartow by 1920 ten years later that
black population was up to 40,000 and it
was growing every single day
the trains arrived
from the south that great influx of
people of immigrants and of
african-americans into Detroit had also
created an incredibly bitter backlash
the Ku Klux Klan had come out of the
South in the last days of the 1910s and
come north to recruit members and its
message combined the kind of virulent
racism we associate with the Klan with a
profound anti-semitism a profound
anti-catholicism a profound attack on
the foreign-born and in that appeal the
Klan found a lot of members 35,000
Detroiters joined the Klan by 1925 at
the same time as African Americans moved
north whites in Detroit all of a sudden
started to demand a greater degree of
segregation they no longer wanted
African Americans in the same theatres
with them or in the same restaurants
with them but most of all what they
wanted was to keep african-americans out
of white neighborhoods now that was
something new prior to the 1920s
african-americans who were
overwhelmingly poor generally lived
right alongside poor white people if
you're an african-american who is
well-to-do as most of dr. sweets fellow
doctors were they generally lived in
white neighborhoods no one really cared
but now all of a sudden that was
changing it was okay for African
Americans to live in this area called
Black Bottom which was one of the
poorest neighborhoods right out to the
east of downtown that was okay but if
they tried to move out of Black Bottom
all of a sudden all the forces of the
marketplace said they couldn't all of a
sudden Realtors started to say we won't
show black people houses in white
neighborhoods hadn't done that before
all of a sudden mortgage lenders bankers
started to say if a black person wants
to move into a white neighborhood he
can't have a mortgage
all of a sudden insurance agents started
to say if an african-american buys a
house in a white neighborhood we won't
insure it and if by some weird
coincidence of forces an
african-american still managed to cross
the color line and move into what had
been an all-white neighborhood there was
every risk that his neighbors these new
white neighbors would try to drive him
out with physical violence now for the
first three years that ocean lived in
Detroit
he didn't confront this segregation he
rented a house down in Black Bottom at
the start he started to build his
practice with all black patients but
then you know life changes he met a
woman young woman they fell in love they
got married they had a baby he didn't
want to live anymore
in the poorest neighborhood they moved
in with her parents who happened to live
by the way in a completely all-white
neighborhood but you can kind of imagine
how that works after a while you don't
really want to be living with your
in-laws anymore I'm sure they were very
nice people but you just don't want to
do that he was a successful doctor he
wanted his own home so in the spring of
1925 they went house hunting and they
found just what they wanted at 2905
garland Avenue a corner house very nice
bungalow only built ten years before
four bedrooms very attractive house
they put down their downpayment in early
June of 1925 they got ready for the big
move and that's where the terror really
started because what dr. sweet
understood was how risky a move this was
he understood that he had to make
preparations for moving day he's
supposed to move in in August but he
pushed that date back till September 8
and the reason was really very simple
September 8 was the day after Labor Day
and the day after Labor Day means that
just summer vacations over
the men in the neighborhood were back at
work the kids were in school
temperatures would be a little cooler he
asked for police protection for move-in
day she didn't trust the police which
was full of Klansmen and so he started
to prepare for his own defense that
summer he gathered up a huge cache of
weapons ten guns pistols rifles hundreds
of rounds of ammunition he had two
brothers who just by coincidence
happened to be in town at that point so
he asked two of his brothers to come
with him on moving day they rounded up
some more friends and all of them agreed
that they would be in the house the
first couple of nights cuz that's of
course when the danger is baked and then
I'm moving days September 8 1925 they
hit all the guns at a big gunnysack they
put all the ammunition in a brown
satchel and they snuck it into the house
they hid it in the upstairs closet and
when night started to fall Oshin and
Gladys they left the baby with the
in-laws that's too risky ocean and
Gladys his two brothers and their
friends gathered inside the house
and sure enough September 8 the mob
formed just as it was getting dark
hundreds of people out on the corner and
they waited all night for that attack to
start and it didn't nothing happened
next day passed in a kind of ordinary
sword away and then they gathered again
there were nine people in the house by
about 8:00
o'clock that night 8:30 that night ocean
Gladys one brother this time and some
friends the other brother hadn't shown
up yet he had a tendency to be late for
things crowd gathered again the men
raced upstairs and they sat in the
upstairs windows with their rifles
waiting for something to happen been
about 8:25 something did something very
small actually happened and the rocks
started to fly at the house it started
to hit the sloped roof one of them broke
one of the upstairs windows dozen rocks
maybe and the men upstairs opened fire
about thirty shots two people were hit a
young man who was boarding in the apart
of the house across the street he was
hit above the knee another man by the
name of Leon Greiner who lived down the
block he was out on the lawn right
across the street chatting with people
up on the front porch bullet hit him in
the back passed right through him killed
him almost instantly and so the police
who were out on the street came rushing
into the Suites house and immediately
arrested all eleven people inside and
within a day all 11 of them ocean and
Gladys the two brothers the other
brother had arrived the two brothers and
their friends all 11 of them were
charged with first-degree murder and
that's the first part really of arc of
justice and if you followed that story
and it ended there well of course it
would be a local story oh gee just one
other part of the tragically long
history of racial injustice in the
United States and it would have ended
right there except for a stroke of luck
because it so happens that in 1925 the
nation's leading civil rights
organization the n-double-a-cp
had decided that it wanted to mount a
major national campaign against the
segregation of the cities the imposition
of residential segregation in places
like Detroit
they've been
at it for about a year actually but the
leader the n-double a-c-p a brilliant
man one of the brilliant minds of the
20th century man by the name of James
Weldon Johnson James Weldon Johnson
realized the campaign wasn't going
anywhere
wasn't dramatic enough it didn't have a
center to it didn't have a story to tell
two days after the sweet surest tiny
little news story passed across his desk
from the New York newspapers
n-double-a-cp Zoo was then based in New
York tiny little news story passed
across James Weldon Johnson desk eleven
Negroes arrested in Detroit James Weldon
Johnson knew he'd found what he needed
he immediately dispatched off to Detroit
his extraordinary assistant Walter White
Walter White was a young man
extraordinarily ambitious young man
african-american from Atlanta
he was a blond-haired blue-eyed
african-american whiter than me but he
was an african-american man of absolute
intense energy sent him off to Detroit
to organize the Suites defense and he
did organized all the details made sure
the Suites are the right people to be a
symbol for this new crusade lined up
everything except one little thing they
needed a lawyer took him about a month
until they figured out most brilliant
piece of Oh bliss attea Ken why not hire
the greatest criminal attorney of the
day maybe of any day Clarence Darrow
isn't what they set out to do was to
find Clarence Darrow Clarence Darrow
worked out of Chicago is probably most
of you know but as it happened Clarence
Darrow happened to be in New York City
at the time they were looking for him he
was visiting his good friend Arthur
Garfield Hays from those great names he
was staying over at the Haze's
brownstone James Weldon Johnson was a
man of a lot of connections he knew just
about everyone who was worth knowing and
so within a couple of hours he'd managed
to get an appointment to meet the great
Clarence Darrow and to plead the Darrow
take on this case let me just describe
what happened
the undead a CP secretary James Weldon
Johnson arrived at Hays Greenwich
Village home with Walter White
Arthur Spingarn who is a white attorney
of impeccable credentials who ran the
n-double-a-cp legal arm at those days
arthur Spingarn and Spingarn slaw
partner Charles student in tow they were
ushered into the guestroom where they
found Darrell propped up in bed fully
clothed but still looking exceedingly
comfortable despite his advancing age he
retained the broad shouldered barreled
chested body of the workman he'd never
been his face though had grown old his
dappled skin sagging from his high
cheekbones the furrows around his mouth
and eyes deeply etched a forelock of
unruly hair gray and thin fell over his
forehead at the celebrated attorneys
gray green eyes locked on his visitors
and his brow knitted in concentration
though there was no doubt that his mind
remained as agile as it had ever been
his head at the n-double-a-cp 's
national legal committee Spingarn took
the lead and laying out the details of
the case a presentation he handled with
expertise a decade later
Dara would recall how Spingarn z' words
had stirred the idealism of his youth
when the great abolitionists had graced
his father's humble Ohio home I made the
usual excuses that I was tired and
growing old and wasn't physically or
mentally fit he recounted I knew that I
would go and when I was making the
excuses I've always been interested in
the colored people
I've lived in America because I wanted
to the ancestors of the Negroes came
here because they were captured in
Africa and brought to American slave
ships and have been obliged to toil for
300 years without reward when they
finally when they were finally freed
from slavery they were lynched in court
and out of court and driven into means
squalid outskirts and shanties because
they were black or had a drop of Negro
blood in their bodies somewhere I
realized that defending Negroes even in
the north was no boys job although boys
were usually given the responsibility
the others in the room that evening
remembered the conversation a little
differently when Spingarn was finished
talking Darrow offered him the subdued
sympathy for which he had become famous
yes I know full well the difficulties
faced by your race he said I'm sorry mr.
Darrow replied Spingarn whose
naturally swarthy skin had grown even
darker after a summer in the Sun at his
Dutchess County estate but I'm not a
negro embarrassed Dara turned to student
whose face was the same shade as
Spingarn z-- well you understand what I
mean he said I'm not colored either
student answered finally Dara looked at
Walter White well I wouldn't make the
same mistake with you he said well I am
a negro
white replied Dara broke into a smile
that settles it he said I'll take the
case
now I'm not going to recount to you the
courtroom drama that occupies a lot of
the second part of arc of justice
because after all I am here to convince
you that you actually want to read the
book not just hear me tell the whole
story to you but let me just give you
one critical point when Dara went into
that Detroit courtroom in November of
1925 he set out to do something really
quite extraordinary what he set out to
do was to make the jurors who were a
white all of them were white see the
incredible burden of racial injustice he
wanted to make them see the southern
segregation system he wanted to have
them hear the Clank of chains to hear
the crackle of fire to smell the stench
of burning flesh and what he also set
out to do was to make that white jury
see the incredible corrosive power of
the northern system of segregation that
was just forming to see what was
happening in their city here's what
Darrell part of what Darrow have to say
to those jurors I do not believe in the
law of hate I may not be true to my
ideals always but I believe in the law
of love and I believe you can do nothing
with hatred I'd like to see a time when
man
his fellow man and forgets his color or
his Creed we will never be civilized
until that time comes I know with the
Negro race has a long road to go
I believe the life of a Negro has been
full of tragedy of injustice of
oppression the law has made him equal
but man has not I know there's a long
road ahead of him before he can take the
place which I believe he should take I
know that before him there is suffering
tribulation and death among the blacks
and perhaps among the whites I'm sorry I
would do what I can to avert it
I would advise patience I would advise
toleration I would advise understanding
I would advise all those things which
are necessary for men to live together
that's all and it's at that point I
think that the story of the sweets stops
just being history and it touches the
present because what's happened in the
United States and the intervening now
almost 80 years is that the southern
system of segregation is gone it's dead
it's disappeared there are no separate
drinking fountains there are no rules
that you have to ride in the back of us
but the northern system is segregation
that this case was about is still in
place
that in City after City after City in
the United States Baltimore to Boston
New York to Los Angeles American cities
remain divided places they remain
segregated black and white and of all
the cities in America none is more
segregated than Detroit
and so we have a long way to go until
you get to that point that Darrow talked
about in that closing statement and I
think he's right that until we managed
to get to that point we're not a
civilized people thank you so much for
coming I would be more than happy to
take any questions that anybody has or
to talk to more about the book yes
please now I grew up in Boston
Massachusetts and the Irish who came
because of the famine in Ireland so
we're all in just one area they worked
in your homes they were not accepted
even politically and they had a very
very difficult time now in Boston at
that time there were no blacks
it was the Irish so maybe there's just
something in human nature that
segregates the weaker groups of people
in their time well I should say as
someone named Kevin Boyle I think I can
speak a little bit I'm to the Irish
question you're absolutely right that
there has been all sorts of forms of
segregation and one of the things for
instance that the n-double-a-cp legal
teams cared very much about was that at
the same time that the color line was
being drawn in American cities they were
very fearful that the racial line I'm
sorry the religious line would be drawn
in American cities and there were
attempts in particular to segregate
neighborhoods so the Jews couldn't move
into them and the n-double a-c-p which
was very closely connected with a number
of Jewish activists was very concerned
about that I think the critical
difference though between say the Irish
experience or the Polish experience is
that the Irish especially in the 20th
century never faced
the legal prohibitions that blocked
african-americans from moving where they
wish to for instance one of the critical
legal prohibitions that African
Americans came to face for 30 years in
the United States was a practice called
restrictive covenants that what people
would do like people would do is they
would write into their deeds this
property cannot be sold to someone who's
black or sometimes Jewish that didn't
happen to the Irish and so that what a
person someone like my family could do
and admittedly we weren't in Boston
which could be a whole nother story but
what people like my family could do is
we could go her we could afford to go
and sometimes people might turn up their
noses that having us as neighbors but I
my family could say well that's your
tough luck I've got a deed but African
Americans for 30 years in the United
States couldn't do that they couldn't
literally couldn't do that very few
Realtors would say to my family well I'm
sorry but we're not going to show you
anything in that neighborhood right now
if we had the money they were gonna show
it to us now the money that's a
different problem so I think what the
n-double-a-cp understood and what made
there's the African American situation
different with the power of law that
didn't apply yes there's been
discrimination and in fact this book
talks a lot about the discrimination
that afflicted a loss a lot of ethnic
groups but there was a qualitative
difference and at the power of law yes
sir
Kevin what motivated you to choose this
particular subject - math is historic
well now or not a novel but a historical
documentation I think three things I
guess when you say that it's awful to
say that because then you have to try to
remember that you said three so if I
come up around just kind of ignoring it
partly the power of the story I love to
tell stories
and this is a great way i this is just a
very powerful story partly Detroit is my
hometown and I very much wanted to talk
about my hometown but I lived in it in a
number of years now it's my hometown but
the third thing and I think I did it the
third thing it's the most important
thing is that this story gave me a way
to talk about issues that I think are
profoundly important and that's
particularly the enduring power of
racial segregation in American cities
and I think one of the things that I
believe anyways I mean other people may
not feel the same way that it's become
so natural so obvious to us that cities
are divided on racial lines a lot of the
times you don't even notice it I Drive
home from I teach at Ohio State I Drive
home from campus every day to my
neighborhood when I get off the freeway
I'm in an african-american neighborhood
then I turn around the corner and
believe it or not I literally crossed
the railroad tracks and I'm in an
overwhelmingly white neighborhood and
you just don't think about it this story
says we'd have to think about it yes sir
the date being in 1925 and Clarence
Darrow was otherwise occupied that you
are yes sir is there a historical
connection to the Scopes trial there is
now yeah in the summer of 1925 Clarence
Darrow had fought what became his most
famous trial though he certainly had any
number of other famous trials which was
the famous Scopes trial in Dayton
Tennessee the sweet case was his next
trial was his next case
I think there is a connection and it
lies at the heart of who Dara was Darrow
had spent his in well not his entire
most of his professional career taking
on cases starting with defending Eugene
debb's in the 1890s and then all the way
through all the famous cases defending
big bill Haywood defending the Bombers
of the Los Angeles Times building
defending Leopold and Loeb defending
John Scopes he taken on these cases all
is a piece because dara'a great desire
in life was to strip away the illusions
that gripped America what he saw as the
illusions that gripped America and so
the illusions came in a lot of different
forms for him for instance taking on all
those big labor cases early on in his
career was a way of making Americans say
capitalism isn't fair it's not just
because Americans believe it is taking
on the Scopes trial was his way of
saying there is no God because he didn't
believe there was taking on the sweets
case was in some ways taking on the most
sacred of American beliefs which is that
whites are inherently superior and it's
exactly that he wanted to show in that
jury room he wanted to say to those to
the whites in the jury in the audience
in the wider world come on take a look
at this case and how can you believe in
white supremacy and so yeah I think it's
all of a piece yes ma'am
how you worked into the jazz the burns
wonderful documentary yeah wish I had
that skill wow it's a great yeah but
this goes into jazz to some extent this
is not this character doesn't go through
then I'm assuming no no in fact in many
ways dr. suite is kind of you have to
think of jazz I think as kind of you
know the edge you know and he dr. suite
was anything but they with the
embodiment of respectability and so I
can't imagine him as a jazz aficionado
in the 1920s but I think where it does
connect up was kind of the whole ethos
of the Jazz Age is where it connects
with the Harlem Renaissance because both
James Weldon Johnson who headed the
n-double-a-cp and certainly Walter White
were both critical figures in the Harlem
Renaissance and what they were doing in
some ways with dr. sweets story was
they're turning it into a Jazz Age story
they were making him into the embodiment
of the Harlem Renaissance ideal if any
of you ever read a novel that Walter
White's first novel fire in the Flint
yeah good because but when it's at story
if any comes out the year before the
sweet trial it's the story of a black
doctor who is attacked by a white mob
intent on killing him and then the next
year oh my god he has fire in the Flint
and what he does is he transforms the
character the sweets Gladys and ocean
into in some ways the characters in fire
in the Flint he makes them a Harlem
Renaissance story and so this he has
very much kind of tied into and then of
course the bigger thing of the Jazz Age
is how it kind of subverts what are
thought of as the social order that's
what jazz is all about what's music
really and it says oh here's something
completely different and that's what
this trial was very much about it was
subverting
what we white Americans saw as the
social order so I think in that sense
it's a Jazz Age story
that's a great question thank you yes
one of the things that contributed to
this rise of the Ku Klux Klan because I
was in Detroit during the 50s and and
there was still that remnants and that
is the large group of the white southern
people moving into Detroit to to again
to get these jobs that that were there
for the picking so that's really true
so yeah well it it it was I would say
the the the strong contributing factor
yeah I think that's absolutely true that
part of what happens in Detroit is that
there's a very large influx of white
Southerners to Detroit as well but and I
guess it's the one kind of edition I'd
say that though it's absolutely that's
absolutely right and absolutely true
it's also been comforting to Detroit her
white Detroiters over the years to say
well but that's the white Southerners
and it's certainly true the Klan was not
just an anti black organization in 1924
this is a part of the story as well in
1924 they had run a Klan candidate for
mayor of Detroit year before the sweet
trial 1924 he ran largely as an
anti-catholic candidate part of his
platform was abolishing parochial
schools and he won he won the election
for mayor of Detroit in 1924 but he won
by a very slim margin he was a write-in
candidate he won is a write-in candidate
in 1924 which happened to be great
because his opponents then took the I
know this isn't really hard to believe
these kind of things happen in those
days not anymore
they challenged a lot of the votes and
it turns out that as a write-in
candidate people had a hard time
spelling the Klan's candidates name
correctly and so they were able to throw
out 15,000 incorrect votes and so he
never took office but he won the
election in 1924 so it tapped into
certainly that southern migration but it
also tapped into kind of anglo-saxon
superiority that was very powerful which
again comes back to your question
earlier this sense of superiority of not
only over african-americans but over the
immigrant masses that were huge in
Detroit over half a Detroit was foreign
born in the 1920s yes ma'am did it take
you to do the research and what all did
it involve that's a great question
at least that the kind of great question
authors love to hear the research took a
number a number of years I kind of hate
to count them and it was some of the
best most enjoyable thing I'd ever done
because what it did was it took me into
places I never expected to go you know
historian spent a lot of time in
archives just looking over the documents
and I did absolutely
I spent a lot of time in archives
looking over the documents but this
wasn't the kind of story you could tell
that way and so among the places it took
me was back down to Bartow down to the
town that dr. sweet is from and that was
an extraordinary experience
now this wonder two wonderful guides to
Bartow Bartow is still a segregated
community in many ways there's a black
side of town and a white side of town
and they had two wonderful guides a man
who was involved in city government who
was very active as to promote
african-american history who's a
wonderful guide and then a man who for
many years had been the football coach
in the black high school well I'll tell
you you want to find an entree into a
community go with the old football coach
he knew everybody and if he vouched for
me doors just opened up to me it was
wonderful
so you know I'm not southern born this
was a new world and it opened up in
wonderful ways to me that was one way
the dr. sweets home still stands and is
a wonderful family the Baxter family
live in the home well one day I got an
email from Daniel Baxter his bout is a
little bit younger than me who grew up
in the house his parents still live
there his dad has since passed on but
his mom still lives there and he said I
heard you're working on a book on this
story would you like to come see the
house
well I was I was there and he walked me
through the house I spent you know a
couple of I took so much of those
people's time kind of looking in every
nook and cranny seeing what they were
seeing that night that's the kind of
research that makes transform the book
for me you know you can talk about what
it's like for dr. sweet just sitting at
upstairs bedroom that night but once
you've looked out the window and see
where that street is it changes so was a
lot of fun to do that
then the writing itself took about two
and a half years and I was lucky in that
because I had a couple of fellowships so
I wasn't teaching that whole time so he
would just sit my study X I wander a lot
and write and that was just a wonderful
experience yes ma'am curious what what
street so you we can do this Detroit
thing it's on garland Avenue which is on
the east side where were you from from
there University of Detroit near six
mile and Lyra noise oh sure I went to
the University of Detroit I know that
neighborhood yeah oh you you went
there's my undergraduate institution
which is a big deal cuz I'm from the
east side too going way over on the west
side you don't do that that was a
different City
Oh a flameless yeah that was like my
first time other people go away to
college I just went to the west side
that was a big deal in my house when I
graduated from my house Mensch
interested in physics oh cool and you
went it I went there to Business one
year and then I went to business school
oh cool see this is what Detroiters do
when they get together so what street
are you from all right side now we're
gonna go to the high school you know
where park sign is park site yeah think
so yes right off the golf course yeah
they try golf course so he says it's
hometown thing so he's on garland Avenue
which is about three blocks off of
Jefferson if you're driving out
Jefferson on the east side you pass you
come to what Water Works Park has a very
big elaborate gateway garland Avenue
feeds into that and so you just drive
about three blocks up which is a very
bad idea these just because it's a
one-way going the opposite way there
should go around the block you can see
it and it sits on the corner just got an
historic
marker as a matter of fact though it's
still the Baxters house yes ma'am sweet
family was accepted by other blacks in
the community at that time because you
mentioned the fact that he didn't want
to be where the rest of the blacks lived
he wanted to go into this white
community yeah that's a really
interesting question his there was
tremendous support for dr. sweet once he
went to trial in fact at the end of I
should mention this actually reminds me
of this but the n-double-a-cp did is it
turned the sweet case into a huge
fundraising effort in about three months
time they raised over $70,000
this is 1925 it's a lot of money and
it's that money that becomes the basis
for the Legal Defense Fund which of
course is the heart and soul of the
n-double a-c-p
they'll add to it over the years and
they'll take some adding to it before
they can hire people like Charles
Houston and Thurgood Marshall but this
is where it begins so there's tremendous
support from him because African
Americans realized the risks of the
increasing segregation the understood
that if neighborhoods were segregated
social services were segregated schools
would be starved for money and they
wanted to avoid that risk they wanted
the option of living where they wanted
then of course if you decide you all
want to live together in a community
great lots of people do that but then
it's your choice not an imposition on
the other hand there was a lot there was
a lot quite a bit of kind of backbiting
and arguing behind the scenes I think it
was less about dr. sweet leaving the
black neighborhood because again in
those days it just wasn't that unusual
if you had money you lose forever you
felt like it wasn't an unusual thing and
there were about 24 25 african-american
doctors in Detroit that was it in the
1922 mid 20s and he knew most of them
that's a small community and virtually
all of them lived elsewhere they lived
in white neighborhoods so it wasn't that
unusual so I think it probably that
tension was more dr. sweets personality
which was prickly
he rubbed people the wrong way quite
awesome and so there was a lot of
tension I think more on that than there
was about how dare you leaves the
community and again his wife as I
mentioned in passing I think his wife
had grown up in a completely white
neighborhood her she was the only
african-american in her high school
because they came from a solidly
middle-class family and they had moved
out to this house much earlier about ten
years earlier no one really thought
about it much and that's why the it was
such a critical turning point that the
world was changing around them and they
realized the risks of that the costs of
that yes sir this might put you on a
spot in some ways but what role did the
labor unions have in automating
segregation no that's a that's a
fascinating question in the 1920s labor
unions in the United State were very
very weak and know that you know kind of
flies in the face of what you think of
Detroit but Detroit was an open shop
town it was almost impossible to operate
a union inside the automobile industry
virtually nobody was unionized inside
the automobile industry and that was the
big employer in those sectors of the
economy that were unionized in Detroit
which tended to be things like the
building trades they were very much a
force for segregation they were
segregated unions themselves a lot of
them and they promoted a sense of white
supremacy among the working men that
they organized not exclusively there
were interracial unions United Mine
Workers for instance but you know
Detroit's not a mining town it's a
manufacturing time so in terms of
creating the segregated system inside
Detroit unions didn't have much of a
role to play because there just weren't
very strong and very large but in the
wider scheme of things unions certainly
played their role in creating a
segregated Society
it's a great question you had a question
man
what God you written others well this is
good a quick plug no it's not it's not
my first book I am I've wrote a book on
in fact United Automobile Workers I'm so
your question there's a nice feed into
that actually though we don't know each
other I just wanted to make that clear
and I wrote a book with a co-author on
working-class Detroit
thoughts the night I wrote a book with a
co-author my wife was my co-author
actually I was her co-author she did
really did all the work I just put my
name on it so we've done a couple of
other books as well thank you for asking
yes what is your next book oh now that's
a tough question I'm still trying to
figure that one out I'm working on
figuring out what it should be I'm
really looking forward to writing
something else that tells a story in a
way that I think in a way that I want to
what that exactly will be haven't quite
decided non-fiction it will be
nonfiction yeah I'm I'm just not
creative enough I think I think it takes
great creativity I admire novelists I'm
reading this wonderful novel right now
and I think wow that's really cool but I
need someone else to create the story
then I just tell it more about do you
see that way yes sir well I was going to
comment on the segregation by the unions
and so forth and I am a skilled
tradesman I am a journeyman tool maker
by my original trade and we are a very
proud person very proud group we're
proud of that I'm not justifying I'm
merely giving you some insight as to how
we think yeah and we we would not it
would be an actual thing again not not
saying it's right when I was at Ford
which I am a graduate of they we had
blacks toolmakers there yes now this is
nearly 50s and they had been there some
times so it it was changing it was in
the process of change yeah you raise a
really important point which I should
have said actually that when
unionization comes to Detroit in a major
ways the United Automobile Workers which
is explicitly an integrated Union so
unionization when it comes to do that's
not to say every member of the UAW was
committed to civil rights that would be
a
ludicrous to say but the UAW was
explicitly an integrated Union and it
did in fact support civil rights
struggles throughout the 1950s and 1960s
so unionization changes in a very big
way in the United States in the 1930s
with the advent of major industrial
unions that's I'm really glad you raised
that point because I think that's a
really important distinction to make
yeah oh one thing that's bothered me
since the describe the scene
if someone were to open fire on a
rock-throwing crowd these days they
would at least get tried for
manslaughter successfully you know in
the sense was there is there something
mitigating the situation that's in the
book that I can take here today you know
you know the concept of using lethal
force against a non-lethal enemy you
know yeah that's really triggered that
in fact is one of the tricky legal
questions the law says that a man or
woman has the right to defend himself
when he faces what he or she perceives
to be and that's a critical distinction
threat to his safety to his or her
property Michigan law at that point had
a very clear definition it probably
still does but it I don't know about the
present day I'm an historian did it it
had a clear distinction of what
constituted a mob fifteen armed people
was a mob thirty are unarmed people was
a mod intent on doing harm not fifteen
people having to milling around but they
are intent on doing harm and so the
legal question that would underlie the
case would be to did dr. sweet and his
friends inside the house have reason
will have a reason to believe that they
were under threat they could have been
wronged legally in the United
Michigan law legally you can be wrong
that in fact you aren't under a threat
but you think you are and it's a
reasonable assumption to make
so that's part one part two is whether
that really was a mob out there by that
legal definition and there is kind of a
that's a critical part of the legal
argument that goes on during the case
was there really a mob or where there
happened to be people was a very hot
night where the people hanging out in
the street and that's no mob people
inside the black community even raised
the question that you raised which is
did he shoot did the people inside the
house shoot too soon then if she had
waited until they were on the front
porch and shot would there been a trial
I had to say who knows that the
historians answer they that's not what
happened but this was a political trial
this was a trial not really about the
legal technicalities but about the
question of race and housing so ya know
those are all serious questions that
people raised at the time did he act too
precipitously did he act with too great
a force you also raised another point
which shocked the everybody right off
the start no one expected that it would
they be charged with first-degree murder
because dad of course in those days
Michigan in those days did not have the
death penalty he hadn't had a execution
in years and years and years and but
they did they would his face life in
prison for it
yes please this story or if it did it
all influenced other books like
intruders in the duster to kill a
mockingbird hmm I doubt that the I don't
know I mean ask the short answer but as
you can kind of tell by now I'm not
really given two short answers but there
is a really fascinating book by Sinclair
Lewis that I suspect it may well have
influenced called Kings blood royal
which is kind of long forgotten but his
back if I had ever went out of print is
now back in print and it's Sinclair
Lewis's one-take kind of on race and
housing and racial identity and Sinclair
Lewis was a very very close friend of
Walter White and James Weldon Johnson
Walter the reason that Walter White had
such an easy time getting his first
novel published which isn't really that
easy a thing to do is because Sinclair
Lewis made sure it went to the right
publishers and they were over at each
other's houses a lot and they had pet
names for each other they were really
buddies so I suspect there's a
connection through that literature but I
don't think that it influenced something
like to kill a mockingbird which is so
southern kind of in its yeah it's a
great book it's a wonderful book but
it's it's so rooted in kind of the
southern experience of race rather than
the northern experience it's very little
on the northern experience of race
because Americans tend to think of
racial problems as southern problems
racism exists in the south that's what
Americans like to at least northern
Americans like to think well thank you
all again